- Welcome back everybody.
I'm hanging out with magician
Asi Wind and Idina Menzel.
Give it up.
(audience cheers)
So, as most of you know, I'm
passionate about writing.
It's the reason we teamed up
with our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
and the preferred pen
for those fearlessly
making big statements.
And speaking of big statements,
you have to see this video
I received from a viewer.
Watch this.
- Hi Kelly.
- [Students] Hi Kelly.
(students cheer)
- How about that for a welcome Ms. Kelly?
Guess what? Welcome to
Continental Elementary School
in Green Valley, Arizona.
We want you to celebrate with
us today a very special event.
We want to celebrate our
receiving a Guinness World Record
for
the world's
largest
handwritten thank you letter,
enveloped and stamped.
We are standing
on the letter right now.
Look at the size of this thing.
(students cheer)
- I love how excited the kids are.
That's so cool.
The students used butcher
paper to create the letter.
It's 85 feet long and
more than 50 feet wide.
And it's not just about breaking records.
There's a lesson behind it,
so here to tell us about it
is the man who started this project.
Please welcome author
and literacy advocate,
Carew Papritz, y'all, give it up.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Nice to see me.
Idina meet Asi.
- Good to see you.
- So this is the craziest part.
So you guys actually mailed that letter?
- Yeah.
- How?
(audience laughs)
- It was a feat, I gotta
tell you when you fold
up a letter of that size.
- Yeah.
- It's like a giant 20-foot-long burrito.
It took it took 15 kids to
- [Kelly] Which also sounds good.
- [Carew] Yeah.
(Idina laughs)
- I mean look at them folding
that and, and the working
with the paper.
But we said to stuff it in
the back of the postal truck
and we sent it to our sister school.
The postmaster
stamped it.
So it's official.
- [Kelly] It's official.
- It official. It's an official letter.
- I love that.
They were so excited
just to hear the kids.
All of them get excited to be
a part of something like that.
- Oh yeah.
- So how did you become an advocate
for people writing letters?
- Well this is sort of an
interesting spiritual story
but I actually worked in
the feature film industry.
I actually worked
on the Universal a lot
a gazillion years ago.
- Oh, welcome back.
- Thank you. It feels good to be back.
But I, I became disillusioned
with the film industry.
- Yeah.
- And I decided I just wanted
to head on out and I ended
up finding a job working as a cowboy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- On a small, desolate
ranch, Southern Arizona.
And it was like coming back to my roots.
My granddad had a ranch when I grew up.
- Yeah.
- And, but what was
fascinating was I started
writing letters out there and
I started creating a story.
And a story became a book.
And the book, you know, came out.
But I discovered the power of
what it was to write a letter.
And what's amazing is
when you write a letter
and you put your time into it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You actually give, it goes
into the page, you give that
to somebody and they
give you the gift of time
- Yeah
- and you receive it.
So it's really an interesting thing and so
- [Kelly] You're a romantic cowboy.
I like it.
- Really? I am. It's really sad.
- No it's not sad!
Super hot. What? No, that's great.
It's, I love writing letters.
I'm actually really into
like personally writing them.
I do it all the time.
Do y'all like writing letters?
Most people just stick to
your phone, I guess nowadays.
Do y'all ever write?
- No, when my son goes to camp
and they make the kids write letters too
which is so important.
- [Kelly] Oh I love that.
- It's, yeah, it is the gift of time.
It's, they're taking
time outta their day to
make you important and
like send you something.
That's so nice.
So how did you get
involved with the school?
- Well, my son went to school there.
- Yeah.
- So that was really
cool and a big shout out
to the school 'cause we could not do any
of this this letter
and stuff to the students, to the teachers
to the superintendent and all that.
So, but what was really
cool is they allow me to
do these things and it
brings hope and positivity
- [Kelly] Yeah
to the kids in a world where
it's just, they've got so
much turmoil.
They've got through covid
and all this, and we do this
through letters.
And so the first thing we teach them
about writing a letter is
you do it from the heart
- [Kelly] And you're getting
them away from all the tech.
They're born in a tech world.
Right. So it's like a
real handwritten letter
- And it slows them down.
Yeah. And it's not a text.
It's not, and we're teaching them patience
and we're teaching them gratitude.
- Yeah.
- Because when you write a letter
you end up giving that to somebody.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you give it to your
community or however it works.
So it's, it's, it's such a cool thing
and it's not work
for them.
It's fun.
- Oh my gosh.
It's the best way to immerse
them into learning something.
Yeah.
And to get them, inspire
them to do something.
'cause like, they're not of a
generation where people wrote
you know, they, they don't
write letters generally.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So I think that's really
cool to bring that back.